the pilgrims founded Plymouth Plantation
in December 1620 and promptly commenced
to get sick and died when the settlers
finally stopped croaking they set about
creating a heaven on earth a society
without private-property were all work
for the common good everything was
shared especially bitching and moaning
about working for the common good let's
let the colony's leader William Bradford
tell it this community so far as it was
was found to breed much confusion and
discontent and [ __ ] much employment
that would have been to their benefit II
and Comfort II for the young women that
were most able and fitty for labor and
service did rapine that they should
spend their time and strength to worki
for other men's wives and children
without any recompense and it wasn't
just the men folk who found the
situation unbearable and for men's wives
to be commanded to do service for other
men as dressing their meaty washing
their clothes etc they deemed it a kind
of slavery
neither could many husbands well Brook
it with nobody working everybody was
suffering and in case you think nobody
was working simply because they couldn't
understand a damn thing Bradford was
saying she won this in 1623 Bradford and
the other leaders assigned to every
family a parcel of land this had very
good success for it made all hands very
industrious so as much more Corning was
planted than other ways could have been
a by any means that gov or any other
could use and save him a great deal of
trouble and gave far better content II
in no time at all any general all wanti
of famine has not been amongst them
since to this day America would never go
hungry again
so this week before you drift into your
annual tryptophan induced coma don't
forget to give thanks to the true patron
of this holiday feast property rights
you